il y à un sujet dont tout nous parle
entre amis entre collègues devant la
machine à café
ces mots de passe faux je ne peux pas te
laisser dire ça à l'âne
tu as tout faux on n'en parle jamais et
pour cause ses secrets les mots de passe
je sais stevens et l ironie mais bien
sûr tu me fais honte alan tu ne connais
rien sur rien tu n'es vraiment pas digne
de reprendre la société papa alors là je
peux te dire que j'en connais un rayon
sur les mots de passe alors ne me
cherchez pas très bien le premier qui
n'aura plus rien à dire de pertinent sur
les mots de passe ne reprendra pas la
société de papa défi relevé
tu me fait pas peur steven et là non
plus
[Musique]
je prends la main je t'en prie quel
idiot il n'ya qu'une seule chose à dire
sur les mots de passe en prenant la main
je gagne forcément c'est marrant les
boîtes sont souvent en rapport avec la
personne qu'on aime
par exemple barbara 04 ou kelly 92 bien
observer il est foutu comme mot de passe
il est aussi celui créé pour un contient
trois ans et qu'on retrouve foot hein on
essaie tous les différents mots de passe
qu'on a pu avoir
on finit par cliquer sur mot de passe
oublié et là ça nous le renvoi sur un
vieux même dont on n'a plus de mots de
passe non plus game over alam
ce n'est pas drôle tu viens de faire et
de croix soit c'était papa mais on n'a
jamais dit qu'il fallait que ce soit
marrant merde
soit c'est à toi non c'est pas toi merde
si jamais je ne parle plus peut-être
qu'il s'apercevra de rien tu n'as plus
rien à dire merde non c'est faux j'ai
encore plein de trucs en stock
je t'écoute as tu souffres as-tu
remarqué que souvent il ya un truc tout
le monde fait halal c'est le mot de
passe commun celui qu'on partage avec
ses potes ou sa copine pour spotify ou
netflix et qui est totalement différent
de notre mot de passe facebook ou son
chat c'est bien formulée j'ai eu très
très chaud mais là il est cuit il ya
aussi un autre truc de marans avec les
mots de passe on s'est imposé mais il ya
plus rien à dr c'est leur évolution
à l'époque on pouvait simplement écrire
un monde du type saucisses
et aujourd'hui on nous demande d'ajouter
une majuscule des chiffres qu'est ce que
ce sera ensuite viser moujik aaa
ce n'est pas du tout pertinent à l'âme
tu penses que cette expérience est
universel mais elle ne l'est pas c'est
vrai steeman à part toi
tout le monde a tout de suite pensé à
mettre des majuscules et des chiffres
moi-même vos mots de passe c'est x 5 cm
jusqu'à le g8 elle match qu'il dit et ce
depuis mon tout premier blog j'étais
persuadé que cette expérience était
universel la partie terminée à la ddt ne
dit plus un mot dr miles lui-même en
tant que proches a contesté de cette
famille je me dois de rétablir la vérité
son mot de passe c'est bel et bien un x5
c majuscule j'ai eu 8 l majuscule images
il est le seul à avoir eu directement ce
type de mot de passe
voilà la vérité il l'a tapée sans faire
exprès alors qu'il tombait dans les
escaliers c'est vrai nom il mort puis
cet événement tragique qui a gardé un
fort traumatisme
tu n'as jamais remarqué qu' elle ne
prend jamais les escaliers mais oui
maintenant que j'y pense c'est vrai
qu'il préfère toujours escalader les
façades
tout s'explique
[Musique]
qui de alan de steven reprendre à
l'entreprise familiale
je sais pas je suis comme vous par
contre y'a un truc que je sais c'est si
tu as aimé cette vidéo tu as juste à
cliquer son petit macaron multiprise et
hop ça ta bonne alors les gens sont pas
mal sur mobile à nice du coup clic et je
sais pas si c'est peut-être faudrait
dire un autre mot quand je dis les gens
tu portes de l'équipe pas les gens qui
sont en train d'écouter ce qu'on dit là
je les sors d'où tes stats belge c'est
un gars qui m'a dit une fois que un gars
qui connaît bien le cubain jérôme faut
dire tapoter je crois tapote sur le
macaron